I've heard you like jokes and that you
like science jokes is that true yeah I
like jokes yeah yeah and I got some I
have some jokes as though so you have
jokes you have them with you I'm told
you brought some jokes so God some dogs
will be the first jokes we've heard
tonight let's let's come with you come
here your jokes okay are the kind of
jokes you like is there about yeah I've
got some science jokes okay all right
let's hope you understand up
[Music]
okay the first joke is okay so why can't
you trust atoms why can't you trust
atoms I don't know cuz they make up
everything a neutron walks into a bar
and asks mr. on walks into a bar okay
yeah I think these are just theoretical
situations a neutron walks into the bar
and asked how much for a drink the
bartender says for you no charge okay I
think we have time for one more
pick your favorite last one okay I think
I'll get this one
Tanishq I've gotten all of them so far
I'm just kidding oh thank you a
scientist is reading a book on
anti-gravity he can't put it down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you